pues se sabe bastante porque el
contenido ha sido publicado hace poquito
este contenido expide estipula como
comentaba un corredor de trigo
humanitario que podrá salir en los
próximos días desde los puertos supremos
hasta todos los de los demás países del
mundo a través del mar negro primero
después del estrecho del bósforo en
turquía este acuerdo será verdad será de
una validez de 120 días ha sido
estipulado el contenido que dice que si
no sé si todo el mundo está de acuerdo
una vez pasados esos 120 días cuatro
meses este acuerdo se renovará
automáticamente de un país de ellos no
está de acuerdo a este contenido este
acuerdo quedará completamente revocado
en la firma de este pacto en estambul
esta misma tarde han estado presentes
los dos grandes mediadores entre rusia y
ucrania para poder llevar a cabo este
acuerdo han sido el secretario general
de naciones unidas antonio guterres y el
presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán
ustedes ha hablado de este pacto como un
faro de luz hacia el futuro de una
posible paz entre rusia y ucrania sin
embargo las dos disposiciones los rusos
y los ucranianos están muy separados
entre ellos se han firmado dos
documentos no uno ya que las
delegaciones rusas y ocres no querían
mezclarse primero afirmado los rusos y
después una vez los rusos se han ido de
la sala han entrado sus granos a firmar
su mismo pacto al pacto de texto firmado
es el mismo pero han hecho por separado
para no cruzarse ni verse completamente
diez minutos